AND SILICON VALLEY IS LEACHING
INTO AN ALL-OUT WAR.
LAST WEEK, A PLAN WAS SUED FOR
BEING FIRED BY GOOGLE ON
DIVERSITY THAT WAS UNREMARKABLE
BY NORMAL PEOPLE STANDARDS.
NOW CHUCK JOHNSON HAS SUED
TWITTER AFTER THEY BANNED HIS
SAME THING.
NEW VIDEOS FROM PROJECT VERATAS
SAYS THEY VIDEOS WERE BANNED.
MARK STEYN JOINS US TO ASSESS
THE WRECKAGE OF SILICON VALLEY.
WE LEARNED THAT A LOT OF THESE
COMPANIES SUCK UP TO THE
REPRESSIVE AUTHORITARIAN
GOVERNMENT OF CHINA AND SQUELCH
SPEECH FOR THE SAME OF MONEY.
>> CHINA IS THE LAST BIG MARKET
TO CONQUER.
IT DOESN'T REALLY MAKE A LOT OF
DIFFERENCE IN MONEY TERMS.
BUT DOWN THE ROAD THEY SEE IT AS
THAT.
IF YOU LOOK AT IT IN PARTICULAR,
THE INTERNET HAS IN THE LAST TEN
YEARS, I LOVE THE INTERNET AND I
PREFER THE INTERNET TEN, 15
YEARS AGO.
THE LAST DECADE, IT'S DWINDLED
DOWN TO FACEBOOK AND GOOGLE WHO
BETWEEN THEM TAKE 84% OF THE
DIGITAL REVENUE ON THE ENTER
PLANET EXCLUDING CHINA.
AND THAT MEANS THAT GOOGLE AND
SO THEY'RE BASICALLY BEYOND
MARKET PRESSURES AND THEY HAVE A
HIGHLY IDEALOGICAL POLITICIZED
STAFF WHO AS WE SAW IN THESE
LEAKS FROM TWITTER, BASICALLY
ARE -- ARE GLORYING, REVELLING
IN THE POWER THEY HAVE TO DO
DOWN THEIR IDEALOGICAL FOES.
>> Tucker: SO I DON'T
UNDERSTAND.
SIMPLE QUESTION SINCE I LIVE IN
WASHINGTON.
YOU HAVE TWO COMPANIES THAT ARE
OPERATING WHAT IS TEXTBOOK
MONOPOLY TO THE DETRIMENT OF
CONSUMERS IN THIS COUNTRY.
THEY'RE A THREAT TO THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT AND MORE POWERFUL
THAN THE U.S. GOVERNMENT AND
THIS FROM HAPPENING THROWS UP
THEIR HANDS AND SAYS I DON'T SEE
A VIOLATION HERE.
THIS THREAT.
>> I THOUGHT SENATOR LEE WAS
UNIMPRESSIVE ON YOUR SHOW ON
IN A SENSE WE'RE IN A
POTENTIALLY DANGEROUS SITUATION
HERE.
AS YOU SAY, THIS IS A DE FACTO
GOOGLE FACEBOOK MONOPOLY AROUND
WANTS FACEBOOK BE -- SHE'S
CAUGHT ON TAPE WITH ZUCKERBERG
RESTRICTION OF SORT OF RIGHT
WING POPULOUS MOVEMENTS IN
FACEBOOK AND TWITTER IN THE SAME
WAY.
THAT SHE WANTS THEM TO BE HER
ENFORCERS.
AND SO I THINK THE DANGER HERE
A SENSE THE NATURAL POLITICAL
INCLINATIONS OF FACEBOOK AND
GOOGLE ARE INCENTIVIZED BY
CRAVEN POLITICIANS.
THEY'RE BEYOND COMMERCIAL
PRESSURE NOW.
ONLY ANTITRUST PRESSURE IN
BUT IN A SENSE THEY HAVE FOUND A
POLITICAL SWEET SPOT THAT
INCENTIVIZES THE LEFT WING
THOUGHT CONTROL THEY'RE ENGAGING
IN.
>> Tucker: AND YET REPUBLICANS
CONTROL ALMOST ALL LEVELS OF
TELL ME WHAT THE POINT OF VOTING
FOR THEM IN THE FIRST PLACE WAS.
I'D BE INTERESTED TO KNOW.
>> THAT MAY BE A VERY LONG AND
DEPRESSING PROGRAM.